I leave in Iowa
way bad you delay me wanna be half
doesn't matter how much I can you please
get a time and a terminal and game a we
want to send you up do you want to
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared her with fine
[Music]
do you need a ride do you mean tonight
do you me like do you need a ride do you
need with parrot and Chris welcome to do
you need a ride this is Chris Fairbanks
this is Karen tell Gareth we're heading
in LAX to the airport I'm already
getting nervous but I was in the middle
of the story because who was who sister
who was the dog the dog talkin is my
grammar school teacher mister stuff
Lou's wife Nancy's older brother her
maiden name is Nancy docket and Nancy DA
I didn't know about Nancy Dakin so
before we were recording I was yelling
at Karen for never having mentioned that
I raised my voice and very I was upset
but then times and then I started
talking about the time I thought doc and
winger it was a wig or Whitesnake I
think it was a winger Dokken winger in
scorpions and that'll end Brendon Walsh
who had had some stadium beers it wasn't
the whole stadium to be honest they they
blanket it off like they put up curtain
so it was half of this big round you
know well I mean look it's not 8 1987
anymore no no and there was a lot of
they had like a coat-check and then a
walker and cane a ponytail dome outside
yeah they had a place where you could
comb out your ponytails and did carnival
Def Leppard mirrors and for all the
extra coats yeah the dead roadies there
that would comb your hair or carnies and
and and Brendan said we're going to get
on stage and I've never done that at a
real rock show and so
because he used to work there for the
festival lights or something that's
Christmas banging hello instruction so
he knew his way around the stage and we
just went to the security guy and said
hey we got to replace a light on the
drum kit or something the guys like okay
and during the concert just let us walk
down there I always get nervous at these
airport cops hikes and or they think
it's weird that I'm talking and no
microphone I think but by the time they
put it together we're already past yeah
yeah wait a minute were they doing an
in-car podcast
wait a minute are they referencing
Dokken comedic Lee I think I'm ow he
mouthed the words darkness okay so
anyway you said you worked for the
football yes yes no I just said yes yeah
we the light bulb went out on the face
of the drum kit and we got to go replace
it in between songs I just said a really
specific thing yeah and the guys like oh
all right
and so we walked down there we got we
did get behind the drummer and then we
during rock you like a hurricane
we ran out on stage on each side of the
drummer which scared him this was
shortly after 9/11 everyone on high
alert and he dropped his drumstick and
was startled and then Brendon on stage
got next to the guitar player and
started head bang and he did the right
thing I panicked
and I was like kind of break dancing
like doing the robot how I can dance
yeah and right about there right away
within five seconds
giant men in black shirts tackled
Brandon and like we're giving them
elbows really roughly yang demastes I'm
sure you can't just [ __ ] go out well
of course it was dead but there's a link
which sorry which one of the terminals
by okay um boy and it's extra crowded
here at LAX it's a nice Sunday afternoon
everybody's here not just to pick up
loved ones but just to drive around
we're to meet lost line meet the man of
your dreams lax thanks for listening to
diddle I love but then they just let
left me on stage too
long I danced until I walked off on my
own accord and then and then a security
guy did grab receive me and I said come
on don't be mad no one gets on stage
remember the 80s again I don't care he
put me up front I watched the rest of
the show
Oh from a better like a seat that people
spent hundreds of dollars on [ __ ] yeah
but Brandon was outside like get it
talking cops out of arresting and he was
there around police I came out and I was
like what a great showing he was outside
I'm Michelle balloon was there in
different seats watching the whole show
and she was like did you see those two
guys get up it's like she didn't even we
were far away
that's hilarious really it was something
it was wait credit to Brennan Walsh he
did talk his way out of getting arrested
yeah yeah because he kind of should have
been arrested I mean like both of you
well or trespass I don't think that
jumping on stage at a concert isn't
something they necessarily like want to
do the paperwork for right right
you know the huge paperwork there's like
so many forms they have to fill out a
w-9 or they just don't care that much I
guess
that's so good yeah I it was really fun
I haven't also I was okay with
disrespecting those bands because all of
them were just getting on stage going
like the guy from a winger was like and
or white to me
remember wait if it's winger than you're
talking about Kip Winger which is one of
my favorite Don Dokken and Kip Winger
David Coverdale I hear talking about the
band's founder yeah Kip plan yes okay he
was like saying right away there
certainly are a lot of nice pits and off
I was the first thing he's dead and all
these ladies were like yeah
yeah I'm tonight no one's ever
complimented the lobby's asymmetrical
hangers see how he said it again so
progress there certainly are a lot of
night captain Austin
oh yes Prince Phillip oh no it's
believing room winger I hope you guys
are having a good early Wednesday
evening I'm pretty sure it was it was
docking anyone y'all can't
it was docking her with winger or would
like my god you're right no docking was
there I can't remember who exclaimed
this okay I'm not here to I bet it was
scorpions did have a little bit of a
German - no it was just English okay so
I feel like the Navy it was winger cuz
isn't he Kipling her yeah is he English
I think so
I don't know anything about him except
for that his first name is Kip which is
the name that makes me laugh the hardest
next - for a man's name
second only to Kim oh I just realized
we're gonna get a lot of tweets about
winger and white sniffalicious yeah yeah
that guy what a happy limo driver he
just leaped into traffic happy waving a
sign and we all loved him for it and I
applauded I don't know joy next time I
jaywalk I am going to jump up and down
and wave my arms and be so happy about
it because all of us almost honked and
wave daddy yeah I was like he was
flashing those pearly whites he made it
fun that he was jaywalking and making
everybody stop real quick he made it he
made us laugh again he made it seem like
it was a simpler better time a greater
time can I taught her America sorry I'm
so sorry no it's okay I was I'm done
with my presidential contenders whoops
so I was just trying to say and it's
funny that I would start that by think
can I talk to so some nice ooo can I be
next but I just meant can I just address
this haircut I was given
it is a heartbreaking experience to me
when I get my hair cut and when I leave
I feel like the haircut is the
hairdresser trying to tell me I think
you're ugly oh you're taking offense to
what they decided to give you we had a
very first of all I love this place I
love this person whatever but we have I
think we have two details of discussions
because I start to tell her about the
layers that I want in my hair but I
always say it like but not too many not
do last part and then she's like no I
totally get it and then as she's cutting
it she goes but can I even it up in the
back and not I never want her to do
because that's what ends up giving me
the Rachel which is the haircut that I
fear and get from people constantly
right sorry I'm just gonna I am
listening
no I'm already done no I but I I don't I
think your hair looks good thank you
what do you not like about it see this
see how short this is oh that is
layering that's layering and it's what I
wanted was just layers up in the front
just to like lighten up the hair in the
front but not to touch the back it
doesn't matter this is a [ __ ] doll
well when someone does like can you
think of early you know how okay what do
you mesozoic know Goldie Hawn in the 60s
and her hair I like on laughs and she
had to like her hair was like round on
top but then it came in at the neck but
then there was like a sleek mullet yes
the missus radio its Milan why do I like
that hair you do why cool that's what
they gave me so you must be loving this
sighing oh God I knew I could turn this
into a compliment oh is that him very
his we're all rig yeah he's there hey
let's just be illegal and pick him up
right in the stop way yeah is it called
a stop way a crosswalk
oh not the microphone was a skew how are
you I'm sorry that we love it's okay no
no that might get far yes hi how are you
hey how's everybody good keep saying hi
like that it's a lot like saying check
one check two hey thanks for getting me
carrots where were you high number one
uh Philly and DC Oh Billy soaking it up
by coconut philic and cheese day I got
punched I punched and I got plugged good
good good good good that's that's
everyone get Bert does I haven't looked
at him yet do they have a black eye
I have black eyes and a black guy with
me yes got a black eye you did notice I
paused yeah obviously you have a black
eye yeah
a black guy hey how are you hey oh yeah
hey who's this guy you were serious hey
what's your name my name is Gareth and
in your name sir what have I made you
hear about a black voice would you feel
uncomfortable yes yeah who's your friend
is your friend he doesn't have much to
say Garrett well this is this is my
buddy time why won't Tyler speak for
himself because if as a right now he
doesn't know what he doesn't know what a
podcast oh okay and and he also is not
used to people coming to get him and I
at the airport and do a podcast well let
him stare bracket but you're different
what you're like to you Klingon over
avis yeah well actually they're a
sponsor hello wouldn't be cool okay
I'm loves Gareth oh you come ah like a
[ __ ] talk show gala camp this look at
it what a great what a great thing we're
doing and I'm uh
are you good do you need anything you
know would love it the burger oh do I
have anything like eight years yeah yeah
let's get your burger back bar being
that guy with that we always have some
burger guy that jumps in water
is a good live um I do and so I will
navigate definitely announce it to
people yeah there's many people coming
over as possible yeah you you and you
and I always forget that the name of the
dude you do your podcast David I gotta
forget it
I think I said name I said Dave's dead
mother's day he was on no there's a lot
of research so there's two of them now I
honed them and there's two I'm of course
newest I do honestly oftentimes when I
said when I think of them as Dave I
forget the Anthony when I think of him
Anthony I think he's the drummer from
Van Halen tough face yes LaBrie slope
you're going to oh god forbid if you get
mad at me again again okay wait yeah
okay okay the only reaction he have yeah
no either doesn't listen to him where he
comes out I recently came at it with a
knife that's always a fun game yeah no
you attack me with a knife what are you
nice great bully why what happened no
you know there was a cake and there was
an ice and Dave just decided I'm happy
with it was it was for the purpose of a
video but it was also a very sharp knife
that he was and it's not one of those
things where we drew it up in the sand
before it like hey yeah come maybe with
a knife tonight
hey let's just make a video look at this
ladies and gentlemen the dollop yes but
don't a dollop that is the magic sauce I
know is the dollop going moving into
video of casting what do you mean what
are you going that hard I don't think I
you know he doesn't know what a vidcast
oh oh oh be casting be casting we
actually are I do not do that just
because we never know when we're going
to record how are you guys
we the very first episode of do you need
ride we had GoPros throughout the car
and later production we had a camera on
the hood we had we had some dude in the
back and and it was it was we didn't
enjoy it no way it was not that maybe
because a little bit of a stressful
podcast to do no way once we're home
once we leave LAX everything feels
better
okay yeah that's how everybody feels
about LAX I mean there's nothing good
happens there it is the absolute worst
airport especially when you like I was
in Philly this morning and you're like
oh you just it takes eight minutes yeah
to actually check out mm mm aha sorry
it's announcing oh god how do I not know
how to Chris turn laughs we can't do
this well we're going wherever we're
going
i sorry I it always ends up we're
navigating it's a so yes it is the
answer to me sweating right now trying
to figure out Google Maps yes it is
stressful okay I don't know why or for
you there's enough happening in the car
yeah we're doing a village we're just
getting on the okay 405 north
oh that's and then if we get pulled over
how do we explain this um what do we you
guys what I say immediately is Apple is
it illegal for me to talk into a
microphone while being a passenger sir
okay all right put your gun down and I
demand to see a superior even though
we're just on the side of the road so
that's what I do is I watch those
YouTube videos and try to pick up little
details on how to get out of
predicaments with the police don't know
enough of the law like there are always
the ones where the guys own them well
here's the thing that you're golden
you're white man so I congratulations I
am white but I'm turning Hispanic in the
fall I can't do that the announcement oh
well I have decided are you is that a
spoiler alert it's a spoiler it's a
spoiler but it's an exciting time did
you get a part of a new one day at a
time
yes I'm suing a one day at a time I'm
doing a six episode arc and I wanted a
Hispanic guy and I said I'm available to
be Hispanic he said let me try yeah well
they're casting all white people as
Asian people in movies now so I'm like
it's my always wanted to play a Native
American in a movie so I go to my guy
he's the best
my manager or my theatrical agent person
he always is telling me that there's
just simply not work for and I
understand why he's saying it but
he's ours never he's like well Gareth
you're a Europe you're a white dude what
are ya if you were Asian or Latino I may
be and I'm like big reason for the swim
maybe you should to have different
clients as that's who you believe in
it's a reason why I'm showing you give
him a DVD of workaholic yes I can be
really a majority of entertainment
because actually he says that what's
happened and then I turn on my dad's TV
that's the only time is when I go home
to my dad's and I'm like wow look at all
my friends on television not to say it
right right I also have many black and
Latino friends you another life you know
back here yeah soon at all number three
yeah finally finally can you hurry it up
because people are starting to say I
only hang out with white folks because
I'm not doing this for you but you will
benefit oh we all done online text
timeline yeah go ahead
help Gareth where what were you doing in
Philly and then also the other place to
the other place you you were done your
homework exam your well I clearly done
your homework I was in DC and Philly and
I did a live dollop shows okay well I we
were just talking about a live talking
show oh well that's very different but
better yeah definitely go to one just
different just different a little
different wanna do people so you were
just Hank hanging out with Mark Anthony
with Marc Marquez a and I were yes we
were in the green room and I hang out
with Marc now because again of the
decision I made about fall yeah Latino
and I want to you know start to kind of
get my base going so mark and I are
friends we're doing a podcast how do you
get along with David lazy broth I
thought what if I that's how I really
can't use that well ah
rothmeyer yeah is he quiet realizing
that quiet
no for real Baby Bop is he shy he seems
shy and low-key he doesn't kick it all
in realized there's no it's actually
very stiff no
taking days are dead I don't want to
David Lee Roth well good I like David
this is a hell of a performer yeah and
he's a showman hmm so I've always we've
always gotten along very well and how
long have you done the dollop with Dave
I'd Lee Rock coming up on about three
years oh well yeah which that's very
weird that's like how long you and I
have been there yeah
how often are you guys able to do this
oh we need as often as we want that's
the fun thing okay we've reached this
point where it's like hey we might wait
a couple I'm sorry is that I can we
talked about at least set it to Morgan
Freeman it is it you're all I the very
least yes I'm listening to what it
sounds like and we can you really can't
hear this so the fact that it has
announced your but people really it took
the audio separated it into different
channels is not good Don or they could
just you know go to one of your shows
and kill you that way yeah I never I've
definitely you know there's definitely
ways for people to kill old man I can
come on right down the number for this
dinosaur van that says really we're
going to let I do this tonight too
because if you actually it's easier
Karen if you just text escape to
three-one three-one three-one which is
always a fun text to send to any number
right I want to escape into brontosaurus
land out stay put
that's gotta be a good job hey by the
way what are you why is about are you
what are you
what's this lizard email it's just as
pterodactyls flying over palm trees but
then it's said and it's driving it and
it's a camping van I can't prevent a
hand serve as a big camper wait a minute
you can live in that van it's someone is
this someone's real-life version of
Jurassic Park its camper van halen's
another oh I love that car yeah this is
a mashups of camper van Beethoven and
Van Halen but incredibly unpleasant
thank you not a good company you want to
hear it later
we're violent this is a nightmare with
the violin
that really was big and it's not even
real by a violent example I was happy
that day they turned a cracker which a
violin sample was one of my favorite
clowns that is a good one when I see
covered in blood why look at theatres
what theatres did you do in DC and
filling [ __ ] I hope they were honest
they it was the place is called 9:30 oh
yeah
which time are all the shows there
immediately I assumed we had a show at
9:30 yeah it was at 8:30 yeah that's
that's perplex me a little late uh we
were not late but I had the whole time I
was there I was like what time is this
start right and then we did the truck
Adaro in Philly oh cool that's very cool
I'm just I I guess I'm really sorry
everyone that I can't figure out how to
silence my phone I guess I don't often
do well okay but if people can't hear it
then it doesn't matter yeah and we can't
like you said they could just kill me at
a live show anyways right I almost got
killed backstage last night
why yeah I really tell well they've had
a knife all right Dave murder Fowler
yeah yeah I mean he was jokingly coming
with a knife but it was so realistically
sharp and so very near him that I was
like oh man this joke could go south
there was peril of anybody in the world
who you would believe would turn from
funny joke stabbing into real multiple
stabbings right right he's one name on
the list he's just got that look there's
no doubt it would be it would be and I
would be like I'd be like a jail talking
about Epona be like I know you were
kidding
Joe is I'll have to prosecute on this
phantom ahead and I asked just if you're
not a doctor you don't know where the
vital organs oh that and this love blood
lines are look 18 stabs you're going to
hit something yeah is it too late to say
that I had a show at Stage five 12 in
Missoula and I was three hours early is
it too late for that joke oh I've been
scared off it's it's it's false but I
you know it would have been great at the
time but then there's it there was a
sound thing with the phone and then I
got sidetracked anyway back to the
Anthony who used to be married to JLo
stabbed yep new in the media but you
Christie put all the facts and that's
what matters
we've got the cliffnotes oh that's fine
and those shows went well then no and I
don't want to talk about yeah I know
they were great they were very fun as
yeah you guys have merch we have merged
we have a book that will sell after some
shows and then we'll sell posters an
audio behind them and take pictures
we actually there is an audio version of
the book oh cool and but it's not a hard
book to read what is the book is called
the United States of absurdity Christmas
oh I thank you for asking
yeah a lot of people have seen it I
don't have people read a lot of people's
penis well looking at books is on us as
good these days that what we're going
for not a lot of people realize in this
sort of clickbait world just seeing a
book cover makes a big impact yeah
really good and so we have that book and
it's very easy to read and I'm an author
and I some people are saying Pulitzer
anyway like that by the way once you get
in the book busy real your lips hurt you
pause I'll call it peel you-let's you
got to go cue cue yeah like how do you
say Putin I say Putin I said I'm
changing the way I say based on one's a
question ok go Putin soon oh yeah yeah
Putin I said what a pretty pert which
was what I learned from on george w bush
yeah you know well it's an exciting time
and it is always exciting when you fly
into the airport you get to see the
picture of the president you know that's
real ah another picture of him when we
you arrived no but I was walking around
a little bit oh no when I arrived today
and I look around a little and went
close to the International Terminal and
saw that picture of him and it's you're
like okay insanity all right okay normal
yeah it's funny when you I mean he was
already on TV and already ridiculous to
me and now he's just on TV more but when
usually there's a painting that someone
did of him in the Oval Office like
there's all these paintings that we all
got to see them at Benson ball when we
got did a tour of the White House there
was all these cool paintings
and then the what like the one involved
it was like a festival enough AC and the
all the paintings were very official and
then there's like a really trippy one of
Kennedy it was kind of very 60s have you
ever walked around but there's one of
[ __ ] Trump that's that's more if you
think about that that's crazier than him
being present and know that a
presidential portrait of him it's my
point and it's relevant and also second
to that he's got this actual job of the
president feels like though getting his
portrait painted is the most
presidential thing he's done so far all
the other things they keep kind of
ruining each other I know I know it was
pretty presidential when he said that
the first lady of France had a good body
yeah well she works out and that comes
across to acknowledge that yeah and not
to her I think the way you want to do it
if you're a guy is you want to say it to
the other guy yes don't involve her in
the conversation about because that
unobjective eyes did he say it to
another guy or did you her husband has
avenged his own wife who kind of said it
to both o me was that but not to her wow
look at this beautiful how did they whoa
yo whoa you keep in great shape Yahoo
YUM it was normal oh god I really hate
that this is happening right yeah yeah
it is a it's a fun time it's so
disgusting it's a fun time to go abroad
too because if you go into another
country now they are oh yeah I got more
baffled than ever yeah
it's like we went from like smoking weed
to heroine and now we're just like let's
do that yeah we yeah so there was no
gateway president we just we quit we
quit weed and then we got sober and then
we went straight to heroin now shut up
right into our remember when I first
started going to Calgary Canadia for
this little thing is that the term yeah
yeah that's it when you say it all
together okay and then and they were
they did expect you to say sorry for W
and then for a while it was fine but now
it's back to that again I felt or they
know they are connected enough to where
in Canada
they don't really uh well they've just
got ballast it does that sorry
it's not bad but now I'm a okay the
behind-the-scenes uh they have sanded it
they have the greatest guy now
and also George W Bush now seems good
yeah he like really been weird with Bono
on his ranch yeah and you're like it was
this wasn't as great [ __ ] yeah he
wasn't now he's a guy he's like I
respect the office yeah yeah yeah I do
George W Bush that was one can freshen
here with Tyler in the back guys Tyler
is so quick are either of you excited
the Game of Thrones I'm starting yet it
is tonight it's tonight
ah the only reason I never watch you
never you never want to well I'm gonna
get into it though I used to be above it
all so Gareth what happened and then did
you get it you get in right away yes I
was sick uh well I guess I'll see you my
hilarious do the whole bad okay here's
my bed I was sick for can you stand up a
few weeks is the hospital sick no no
which just I don't know why I was sick
but that's the only time I watched shows
and I was putting it off because I don't
care about fantasy dragons is exactly my
Harry Potter type shows but it isn't
that way it's very it's very
well-written and you get immediately
immersed in the like they pull you in
right away with some of these characters
and their relationships and the fact
that they die right away and then also
everyone is having sex there's like it's
really everyone's hot and it's intense
in the action and they're [ __ ] and
there's dragons oh my god might here's
my joke that you really have to pay
attention to the plot when you're
watching Game of Thrones otherwise you
end up masturbating to something
horrifying get it yeah when I didn't
mention all of it
Aaron would I believe now oh that guy's
head get squished a little braids come
out alright undertale work when I had
boilers they feel spoiling they can tree
one I mentioned was the main character
okay you've had seven years so if you
haven't no no I'm the person who I say
ten years I think you're allowed ten
years before we just will be hot I'm
about to watch Super Bowl for three
years ago don't ruin it I just I'm about
to start the wire and The Sopranos
so I the wires another one that has I've
good hated me it's worth it yeah I think
I am gonna are you caught up on Game of
Thrones now I've already been to
Baltimore okay
I just drove through it yeah very high I
should not be a show Ryan seafoods by
their water you won't believe what's
happening in in there
okay but Karen and you love Game of
Thrones I love Game of Thrones um I
watched it from the beginning by
accident I have the same attitude about
fantasy dragons I feel like it's for
boys I know for me but I was home the
night it premiered so I just watched it
and I was so shocked by the first one by
the first episode so I just didn't know
it but when it ended I was like we've
got to do that again yes and that's what
it's like the whole thing and I'll start
it and it's not a boys show it's like
almost of the most impressive
interesting characters are the lady folk
in it you're exactly right
they've taken fantasy dependency genre a
dragon based fantasy genre and they've
made it it may mean an acceptable for a
girl like me they just love Sex in the
City
yeah they still zoom in on shoes this
dragon - Samantha that dragon flooded it
up all over the countryside right into
Westeros oh just a dragon would like
that haphazard language a strap dangling
from his little Tyrannosaur making
horrible blow job Joe terrible things
taste jokes that are very easy to me
he's blowing flames on Christopher not
Maria I went we were in Malibu and my
mom and sister were on the beach and
Christopher not who played someone named
mr. big that's a dick pic right yes oh
that's why is they start freaking out in
a way that I'm like oh man this is the
first day I'm gonna hang out hang out
with my mom and sister compare all under
this big they were like thank you for is
it big you think for real like it so you
could see him in the corner of his eye
like oh great some more I wonder if it's
big in the distance we got to be four
today in your mansion if you don't like
it oh yeah
ah I know and that is true but I was
just about to say like a zit that's
tough because for the rest of your life
people like how BIG's your dick but the
end of the day is it that tough yeah I
mean - nothing to be fair to my sister
and mom it was hanging out like a
balloon animal oh he had it out I was a
Vanessa yeah they were like how I think
of it I wasn't working right
hey mr. Biggs here Thank You mr. poodles
here I look like a fool it's very
flexible so nice the kids birthday
parties and I would make balloon animals
and I would make did you really yes and
I would make poodles I would do the
thing where you give the tail a little
pouf by putting it in my mouth it sounds
really crazy and sucking on the tail and
that's how you make the little tail we
sure look and the amount of times that
people were genuinely disgusted what I
just done as like you know Batman or
something like that they would be like
Oh Mike I don't want my daughter to have
that yeah well if someone gets disgusted
by that isn't it more about them oh yeah
it's not my fault that every minds one
of the children's Mother's of the time
they put a unsavoury never in their own
mouth no and yeah you say that it's
Batman and people looking right I just
go as silent I'd go with no answer well
yeah in my head I was like this clearly
come on I'm mad but in the process of
balloon making someone will get mad at
some sort of part of the process did
they think you were being funny doing it
a flowchart they would just it would
have my spit on
oh so I'd wipe it off but there will
yeah well now you're turning on me
well it's relieving the kind of grossed
after you make a poodle - then your son
Deschanel and you look at the run it is
different I mean like if you finished
making the poodle you're gonna suck on
this town I don't know guys listen
you've never been in the field being
dead really you've never been in the
field the field
you haven't I've done the work I've been
out there out there on the go start
doing the work out there that's me I'm
not guy I'm the one how many scars did
you get in clone many you did go to
clown Academy obviously Chris they're
not sending nobody's out there it's a
bunch of huge shoe store
a lot of times you make you finish you
complete a poodle balloon and right
before you hand it to the kid you're
like now for the finishing touch
now for my DNA me keep it in frame me
later mellow the dog there you go little
bit no now to get forensic right you
could clone Batman where are you going
that's fun did you get into a like party
mascot or whatever you would call thank
you for using the right channel people
are using the term be fine party mascot
it up here pretty much good did you get
into that because there was nothing else
to do that was acting based wherever you
were living right it was really that I
had I was you know like everybody else
when you moved out like trying to get
stuff going I wanted to be like open for
what do you want to test are you yeah
over the almonds down the town I'm yeah
I think so I think let's do it this was
fun yeah yeah and I 101 yeah I Creek
ascend yet okay thanks normal time here
so I basically had no job and no money
okay no prospects
um and so what year was this this was
last year no I
this was high like 2004 sure sure and so
I really had no idea what to do and I
was doing the sketch show what city left
pizzelles yeah and then someone came to
a show and they were like oh I have my I
do this crazy job where I go to kids
birthday parties and you know do tricks
and all this [ __ ] and you were like I
like kids I like party I was like can I
spit on the balloon first may I spit on
the finished product
and and then I was like okay there was
only two days a week so I meant during
the week I could do whatever and make
kind of enough money to live off of and
so I just put the bullet and just you
know Saturdays and Sundays would just
drive all around this [ __ ] you know
just like what we're doing right now
this is for me
but in a spider right now
unlike I can't believe my life that's
funny I love it I did you ever see Henry
Phillips his movie punching the clown
the first one where his friend he comes
to visit his friend and his friend
dressed as superheroes and he was always
driving to parties and he live with him
and know he was very very discouraged
and my friend one time wanted to film
make a documentary about me doing it
until he went to Griffith Park with a
camera mmm-hmm and he like a creak film
from the bleachers in Griffith Park
and he got this shot of me as Anakin
Skywalker in my car like after I just
put the little weird braided ponytail
and I didn't know he was filming me and
it's just this 45 seconds of the saddest
Sadie Vivian where I wasn't even I
wasn't doing anything other than just
like looking but it was you could just
tell I was dead and I was gone that is
so funny word for a run to though
hideous no I remember in Sacramento I
actually looked up in this phone book a
singing telegram company oh yeah and
called them because I just didn't I
didn't know where to get a job and I
didn't want to just get a regular office
job and I liked sure and they
immediately just over the phone like
sure you can come and do it what are
your sizes and I was like this job must
suck
yeah over the phone Isis immediately
immediately they don't care what my
references are if I've been to jail
doesn't matter we're getting out next
Friday quick list of questions here do
you have both your feet yeah you're
hired
alright sorry you fit into the Betty
Boop dress to get in over here you have
an iron lung and or false I I don't
answer that just get down matter your
sizes we're gonna skip that play the
sizes more than anything right now
don't verbally tell us the sizes we need
them print it out on a piece of paper
write the sizes and bring them down here
what did you guys do when you first
moved here around in 2004 I was because
my car was broken riding my bike with
the
like an et milk crate filled with paints
and I was painting windows all right
yeah I like happy holidays and sale
mattress store because you're an
artistic gentleman yeah I mean I wasn't
going to brag a lot of them were
detailed uh snow landscape yeah you're
not like painting a window one time it
was a shirtless Santa Claus being and
having his haircut I am floating else
with scissors very large sharp scissors
was I returned Farber a barbershop it
was a quartet of it was for a barbershop
yeah yeah answer better VDS to the bar I
mean and it was kind of funny to give
Santa Claus like a hip short on the side
like bartender here cuz I can all right
haircut Santa Claus yeah yeah very Aryan
hardik Mercado and and he he's looking
one of the elves is floating holding a
mirror up and accidentally the look on
its face it's like no I don't really
know if I like this haircut how much
they love it I have zero okay I'm sure
that they will once they approved the
drawing or one of the items I had in my
book that my dad made for me in high
school things that he could paint on
windows and then I uh I passed out yeah
and he put me in dirty clothes so people
said yes okay but I painted windows
since seventh grade
Wow and then I was when you're still
doing that gig though when you're here
to become a famous whatever comedian it
feels bad I like cherry cutting yeah but
the weather was so nice that I enjoyed
it will you tell me what exit I should
be aiming for I'm sorry that I always
what did you do it's Norman I
immediately became famous okay I wanted
to do a okay yeah I didn't when I first
moved here I just didn't have money ever
and a lot of times mooch off of my
friend Laura Milligan
who would buy me dinner like when we
would go out with buy me dinner
and then I ended up getting a holding
deal
oh really right away relatively it's I
mean comparatively yes for now that I
understand how things actually work
insanely fat fast right and then right
before when all that died down as it
always does and right before I was
actually considering moving home because
so much of nothing was happening right
Jay Johnston of mr. show James and Bob's
Burgers said right a put a writing
packet together of sketches I'm going to
be working on a sketch show and you
should try to get a job on it and I was
like I won't because I've never I
flunked out of college and there's no
way it'll happen and he was like put
some sketches that he like made me do it
great and then I actually ended up
getting the job was that mr. show no
that was after mr. show it was a sketch
show called height that I think only
existed for a year wasn't the greatest
ironically it was because they didn't
talk about never it was actually a
secret it was one of the most secret
shows on the W so don't tell anyone
about the hide we're doing kind of an
ironic thing yes irony Network oh that's
great though I know no Brad no no Brian
no I mean I'm nine that's how it
happened so when I moved here right away
I had a manager that could do things
live was excited and I did Kimmel right
away and then it was the years that
followed immediately that I ended up
hitting the Brio nose
okay so that was after you did Kimmel
your drive so the point is you never
make it and if you do it goes away and I
not and that's an up and down right and
then somewhere in there you could just
die yeah that's exactly right sometimes
you go key or just like a weird really
weird Carson someone comes out with you
what says there isn't that one yeah I
mean there's you can't be ready and user
and you won't be you're driving you
should have a lavaliere anything get out
there be quite a bit we have audio of
the end it's like a Risley man
and it's brutal okay a lot of whimpering
the Grizzly man meets Paul Walker yeah
yeah deadly Walker man since I when I I
did a show kind of like five years I've
been called the real wedding crashers I
know a lot of people like didn't they
make that a movie believe it or not the
movie came first yeah it did and that's
and they were fake because I was a
narrative storyline that they're like
that's a fake wedding great yeah this is
the real way yeah and then we went the
weddings like it was by the Punk'd
people and I remember breaking it was a
great show Chris everywhere I permit my
audition for it didn't go well look you
didn't bring the spice to the room like
and it was so bright my eyes yes well
producers are upset when you spit have a
good just hire him get him out of here I
even and I remember thinking like this
might be it and then like the ratings
were so abysmal but ended like so I was
flying from New York to LA and I picked
up like there we are saying that post
and there was just an article where was
a big picture of me and it was just
[ __ ] all over it I think this is
good this is a good this is going well
so what it was like a it was like a
prank show
yes exactly Karen it was a prank show so
you basically go to the wedding with
their real wedding real weddings in the
bride and groom would be in on it
there's no everyone else around back so
what isn't real wedding crashing so
don't hold this your question young poco
a lotta parties aren't I ah caboodle
tails in no time we're all going back to
party eventually no that is my greatest
fear yeah but they have to be spider-man
again because I had to go back one time
after like three years off and then I
got so poor I had to go back and I was
like this is you know what it's not fun
to walk back in the shawshank I miss
there you have other jobs no they don't
care and they do not I look I'm in blood
platelets but that's not a career yeah
it's just two weeks a great income and
and euphoric and it was so common when I
moved to Austin Texas to donate your
living body to experimental science
in laboratory through out the city uh so
many different freeways just ended with
a platelet center or yeah try different
drugs and see how they affect you I saw
it oh your heart rate yeah I can add my
cookies I heart hurts
I took some sort of hair medicine and to
see how it affected your heart rate
okay experimental they hooked me up to
an ECG and they're like yeah it is I
could've had a heart attack
for what for hair growth yeah you know
when I did have a heart attacks when I
got a check for $2,500
oh just that and we're talking about
1999 you lived off of that for four
years we're here yeah something you know
that's whenever you walk into the house
you go this is the house of blood bill
whenever you're walking to talk about
you go this is a meal the blood yeah I
felt that city on blood imagine a whole
house of blood welcome to house of blood
sorry Bevis math nerds can you see that
all right Karen I invented a little I
don't want to go home come on what do
you need very good oh he wanted some fun
Vegas her tummy wants to go to Vegas
yeah I believe I'm allowed to ask for
anything I'm a guest on the show and I
want Vegas it's a very special six hour
do you need a rose right yeah sorry
you know my job you said hamburger no
those kids need a clown I'm a guy who
pretends oh so you're gonna prank the
real wedding dress are back in the night
guys try let me tell you huh you know
prank a real wedding crasher nice try
you'll get burned
does it get up pretty early generally
kids weddings start early you know
Christmas I mean yeah oh you mean like
the old today have some mimosas and
relax a little bit beforehand yeah oh
that reminds me your burgers almost oh
thank god
and then I turned him
function like this salaphi
it's kind of like a knuckle sandwich but
it's uh oh I forgot with that there's a
bunch of them here it's like sliders and
then I hit you again
that is a prank show that I think we're
ready for I just know you I was reading
your bed you can just punch them in the
blood carbon oh you put your arm out the
windows for this yeah double thank you
yeah double thank you oh you can do that
it's an important double thank you ah
see this is what I like is you can hear
yeah sites and the ambient noise it's
something yeah he'll let us yeah what
did you think you were gonna cue Thank
You Carson and thank you Karen and thank
you Karen I don't get it during oh sorry
I took the liberty did I roll yours up
no oh and do not try your survival
potentially I well that's am I ever
right that's my thing Karen I'm down to
the cemetery I come down here a lot I do
a lot of grave walking I have a grave I
just like to look around and sort of
think of what their lives were like and
you know and I like to talk to the
families I really I mean I I'll be
honest I spent two or three days down
here way people drive through so it's a
lot of time I would get on your five I
could have a job yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
that's an absolute nightmare and I spend
all day at the old grave yeah sometimes
I'll get in the fresh plot sit down and
think about the guy you know
anyway I walked through uh I live in a
good area by the way this is a Nigeria
paper tower getting I love what they've
done with the bullet holes yeah no they
put bullet holes in them oh look at that
with shady [ __ ] I mean these you
know that you're in a weird area when
the pigeons are shade yeah those are
there's a weird little conglomerate over
there you know you're in a weird area
where any direction you look there's a
flaming hot cheetos bag anything over
there when there's two Statue of Liberty
tax people on different coordinate data
you know you're in a weird area when
there's two statutory rape tax people
that's why I thought you're good that's
a story you know you're in a weird area
when there's a jolly B yeah that is
jolly B means step on the gas
get out of the area or not a young
burger I have a chicken joy for the love
of [ __ ] we're a franchise you've never
heard of everything's fine
there's eight of us don't tell anyone
is that like Five Guys Burgers jolly
dear made of us yes but there's more
than my three guys moving back cooking
we've connected your burgers ready Wham
haha I love this show this is a real
wedding graduation present I jollibee
decided Olli be jolly be e coli coli a
period that's it that's a my my I
remember making fun of jolly be for
years and then one day I just happened
to do it around my brother and he goes I
like jelly bean and I was like why can
you guys never smoke again was like if
we can't be related
I like jolly use all Effendi's a good
stuff what do they have have you been
there I lived by one I've lived around
this area for a while and yeah that I've
never been there but I they do literally
it's called a yum burger and the chicken
joy is mostly chicken it would be young
burgers made of young oh yeah to be
clear and the chicken burgers made a
choice I made a burger oh yeah it's very
shitty but I know I've never been in
there my friend went there and got
horrible food poisoning Oh
like what did you what were you thinking
wow but I mean what is it just
hamburgers fries oh it's just your
standard Korean fry place oh is it
it's a Korean it has definitely some
Asian affiliations yeah there's there's
a couple languages on the jellybean
measures okay and you go there maybe on
the way to Vegas maybe it's not that
it's not going to drop this thing okay
no listen we're totally going to get a
couple back to jelly be on the way out
of town
so they actually sell jelly bean boxes
Oh curse words like moving box oh your
food and there's holes punched in the
side I don't like there's a cat inside
no there are caps and oh okay yeah
there's a cat that can serve your
it's also just just go there quite an
experience to be open just a cat themed
service interesting it's the best cat
burger box place in the city I think the
cat would serve you food and then go
ahead and eat that same fish yeah no it
is a cat you know they made like I
notice you miss a diminishing returns
yeah yeah people love cats I'm going to
make sense that they were do it that way
better so many so it's easy yeah yeah
plenty of hires a fast food place that's
all cats serving I would call it right
now do you like it Cara be honest with
Chris like I'm looking right at her
absolute place all cats work there it's
called right now what do you think I
can't I couldn't love it Marcus oh she's
busy driving otherwise nothing but
laughter of where we'll hear a fire
that's where I live oh that's great wow
that actually is beautiful thank you
LibraryThing were you win did you
brick-and-mortar it out together
it wasn't easy it was around the
birthday party ordering I don't brick
everybody oh are you hi Rebecca hi
Roberto and I'm order you're out of work
at the same time though right no in
conjunction usually out the mortar and
I'll add the mortar he does nice I mean
did I don't do it any more obvious
knowledge take so long every job oh it
was we've completed nothing I think
there was something wrong with the
process in retrospect yeah looking back
looking back there's definitely some
notes to be have yeah uh Karen you work
with my buddy John levenshtein now right
that's right that is great I'm limiting
the working yes man in Hollywood who
goes he's on the show I work on on
Mondays Tuesdays sometimes Wednesdays
then he goes home works with Gareth for
the rest of the week yeah and then he
takes Friday's off when then he just
goes and swims in his infinity pool
every Friday that he has worked he is
one of the guys who has worked out like
everybody wants to work with him enough
that he's like I'll give you two days
yeah like we'll take it yeah where
exactly and I of course know the answer
here but not just for the ticket
podcasting where do you work well
because you can say it I mean I don't
want to take it away
no I mean it's easier when I hate to
make a horse look like they haven't done
research but I'll tell you just do I
know you're helping me out on one right
now I write on a show called a red rat
development thank you yeah thank you
Chris and this guy obviously shouting
about God on the corner here yeah should
we get the window Wow God he's angry Wow
come on I want our goodness my uncle yo
that happens in a lot of MetroPCS in
this area if you buy a six months
membership to MetroPCS you also get
yelled out about Jesus it's great an
espanol why would you not want that deal
get in there and the minutes roll over
it's got all of them yeah the anytime
plan and then he points up to heaven
when when is it you rest don't do are
you refreshed okay Chris are you really
riding on the new arrested develop I am
he really is right what of it where is
it in women I don't know I really didn't
know Netflix
it'll be on again yeah this isn't is it
similar or different from the last
season they did not it'll be different
because they have we have all the actors
now gather in the same room together in
that em room that was um it's gonna be
like life is amazing sorry sorry guys a
real cowboy is madam yeah he's not
really I do like when you're stuck in
this position right now we're at the
thing where you add a crosswalk and and
you're still stuck in a crosswalk I'm
not trying to go a little further but
people the way the way they look at you
yeah they hate they're so mad
and they're about to do it in an hour in
there well let's be honest none of those
guys drive
well that one guy definitely has a horse
or a mule do you have a race is he like
so what they're aesthetical on the last
episode we walked a guy walked by as we
were driving his both his legs that was
just for all of those a full-circle his
legs were the shape of if you slice the
horse you could put it in between his
legs like a kid's puzzle please don't no
that's disgusting
trying to break the light but we should
probably do a Kickstarter
let's figure out if you can't cut this
[ __ ] sorry man this makes it hard for
thousand dollars just like sores like
bread we got eight thousand oh that's
right let's just buy bread and shape it
like a horse and I got four hundred on
this live feed nice to snake just people
want to see terrible day killing
Jollibee feed them feed them like come
on since they're good and then we'll eat
their livers baby bird give my chicken
joy for god sake okay why did we start
this we're just living for the
Kickstarter we have to do everything
they say like what is that Jesus Christ
it's like a black mirror I don't know so
I was on the Kickstarter constantly
kick-starting it Chris
oh man it's always eating you find out
that you're sleepwalking it sleep typing
at night I'm not changing the kickstart
waking up horrified hey and guys I did
right I know I don't I don't know if you
guys have sponsors but I do just want to
shout out real quick sure settle place
okay yeah right over there above the
bamboo Express Chinese cuisine and it
looks like a house of horrors but still
I think it's important to take your kid
there oh sure the only place where drier
clowns are dentists there is the second
level of what looks like we're in banks
got some sort of war-torn area yeah kids
dental place with a crooked D is just
the scariest building with everything
why why a black awning black browse the
Sun it would make it hotter a black
awning doesn't make sense
and then it's a Children's Dental play
no it's a kids dental place here no
difference okay yeah Oh little goats go
there yes that's right okay sorry that's
a goat dude is weird it's a goat
understand we should have we buried the
lead on that whole story that I like
going to the goat massage
I'll up onto your back oh just a little
close it's like the devil himself in
giving you a bottom there good I was
hard to get place my sound is bad it's
okay it's going to be fine later I did
it's important when you don't worry when
you have a black awning that right above
it have a pigeon dental place so it can
be real with uh oops sorry all the bird
[ __ ] that you might need there we world
that sounds pretty good mmhmm yeah okay
so we got the sound right yeah
everything well it fluctuates in and out
of quality but that's because I just I'm
just turning these knobs willy-nilly
well I treat it like a being a DJ is
that the right way to do pop yeah I'm on
the ones and twos and threes I mix them
each one of these days
yeah but anyway it's fun I think
everyone's a DJ deep down it's you guys
podcast I don't want to tell you how to
do no we don't sound great this is our
podcast everyone's a DJ okay I mean
different one please a doubt is do you
need sorry we tend it woody your hair
and I don't we can sit back there
predicate Dennison know may I say that
that's a questionable decision but I
won't ask we chained it already okay so
another thing already
yeah yes it now yeah now it's called the
hall up okay welcome home I don't know I
feel like I should be in charge of the
dollar one that's right you just sit
back and rip it up there drink four
beers now an Irish accent to get out
weird guys yeah oh yeah I just can make
up some question asked about dollop do
you have one yeah I well I when you're
not an on tour where do you guys do that
do you just do it at your house we do it
at my apartment your apartment but re si
your homeowner I'm not a homeowner okay
no I have very little and I don't want
to talk about I have an apartment Ohio
listen see if it's bragging in a house
but okay well that I don't know no
that's um and you did you make a studio
in there no look at his person banging
arm against window Freneau yeah he wants
out of that menu heaven
crazy with you then she doesn't even
know she's doing that these these
children are like prison bars you hate
your life so much I've subliminally just
pounding a window I never wanted to be a
mother anyway she just knocking a coffee
mug I we do it in my apartment unless
it's the summer and the climate is
terrible oh really oh yeah then we'll go
to a all things comedy studio but for
the most part we just do it in my
apartment so what you do you just do you
have a zoom you have a recorder always
telling recording to my Uncle Mike's and
yeah and you could do it anywhere in a
car for instance I don't do that it yeah
you know it's been dust are doing cargo
bay down ya know I really better some of
that I don't know what's out of it
mainly because I can't stop turning
these not a not good sound
there's too many drops I feel like I
feel like if we get the BPMS right it
doesn't matter what we play because we
would synchronize people's heart we're
BPM the bands are it stands for beep
beep per minute right and it was
basically but you get music to simulate
the human heart and then that way all
the Millennials who are on drugs like
your music that we do it that is that's
a great idea it's like so it's like that
Skrillex guy tell us what music it's a
bit it's like brainwashing through the
heart oh I like it
great yes you love it Chris especially
with the audience hey why not why do you
think what do you sound like you're kind
of thing yeah I know you're a big DJ
guys likes guy yeah well hello pot this
kettle your black Iona I just know you
so I just want to save in the side where
oh sorry right I want to finish the
scent and I want to finish the sentence
right up here on the right is the El
Pollo Loco I used to go to every day
when I don't go and for a while they
would give you receipts and if you went
online and filled out a little thing
with your code you get a dollar off a
chicken breast and I would do that every
day when I go there and that's for best
two years they roll their eyes oh by the
end I mean they're like hey oh that's so
funny CD
you're only eating a player look out of
a pool of cooked chicken no no in your
face you're laughing and you're
horrified yeah it's hard I mean it'd be
hard to react hard it's hard as someone
who's only had it great her whole life
that story is incredibly the shock I've
got work in a field of precooked organic
chicken oh yeah that little name never
never one hormone never a hormone in my
life and any chicken that I ever tasted
you should go to El Pollo Loco though
because they have hormones oh yeah yeah
that's great I like how they put sugar
in there black beans good hair black
beans were putting absolutely I get two
chicken breasts on a black base and I'd
be like why am i gaining weight I'm on a
protein diet for God's sake you you will
back that up right they have like sweet
black bean and it's soaked I can't stop
loving it El Pollo Loco is not a proud
sponsor of do you need a ride and put
your hopefully oh you're going on wait a
minute
it is not it's too sweet these means
these beans are too sweet
look these beans and I'm being serious
right now
they're too sweet you should wait if we
for the love of God they're just too
sweet above a crack curse your dark
sugar being and also here's my receipt I
filled out the online application for $1
off because I the more man made chicken
today I am Georgia breath sorry sugar
bean is the chicken made in a petri dish
copy that receipt to fill up today sir
I'm not a fool that's all you want back
there you're at a fair day you figure
out a fair day well that means I do like
their salts apart yeah it's been a while
since I've been in one but there was
definitely a time where I was the creep
who's like hips what do you need chicken
I used to have a real problem I'd be at
the salsa bar all day at the El Pollo
Loco buying anything just poking idly
standing there it was
Hey I didn't I didn't want to know at
the end of my street and you really
could just go there with a couple bucks
oh yeah you know I was very brainwashed
by the old boy oh yeah is this the most
anyone's talked about a boy local okay
well look though are they really that
crazy now mmm righteous sure that's the
only thing I know that's loco around
here other Isis the tortilla guy other
than that dentist click you see this is
a liquor store that's very Shady
yeah I'm really soaking up the area Wow
yeah you're probably saying how do we
get to a spot like this oh yeah we
answer birthday parties
spit on twiddle tails and and ton of
birthday parties and what I mean I want
to say some of these things out loud but
that's never fun you know that's what
our podcast used to be we just drive
around and read signs
yeah I know I rely was trying but not do
that too much but that dentist was a
house of horrors no we have to do and
that looks like a traveling house of
children enter none leave yeah yeah the
parks finest it's a great spot this is a
terrible area for camping
oh yeah you don't want to have kids here
or adults nobody should be here every
doctor is so scary I went to a dentist
called Western dental okay above a
liquor store on Western and is it a
penguin did it was a penguin it was a
penguin there's a penguin dentist yes
that's a goat's massage if they didn't
have a penguin on the sign no there's
one okay there yeah I wanted it to be
I'm sorry
no it's quite all right I just yes
landed into a bit again but he like he
was put it like I just went to the
dentist for the first time in like four
years since I've been there and they
were like who was this man who did these
things to your teeth and I was like he
said he was the best that's one of
liquor store dentists god this guy swore
he was the back what what were their
main problems with your teeth then Matt
I'm gonna metally put in my head I got a
problem
was a puzzling decision whatever reason
I guess we're not doing that anymore I
don't want to sound like a lead iced or
anything but I've never had a cavity so
shut up feeling really that yeah really
man never in my life so your brush your
teeth alone no you're just lucky you're
lying
no fluoride remember the swish swash
program second all a dream sorry any
wondrous anyone I talked to that went to
my my elementary school does not have a
cavity okay but sorry look back up real
quick like sex well there's no slash
program that's right much more arduous
wash program at Paxton elementary so it
was basically aimed at getting you to
use fluoride
poisonous 100% fluoride everyone go home
and vomit okay it was we a little bit
would trickle into your stomach oh I'd
be not how's your stomach does it have
cavity oh it bleeds Wow God about the
teeth
let's hear a great but they can't stop
falling out that's cavity less perfect
teeth that I have in a jar and your
stomach fell out of you again int
they're unreal Chris yeah I've never had
a cavity no cavity I don't have any of
my original teeth yeah just perfect and
in a jar on my mantel that's great oh I
wish you live there I wish I did too I
live in a shitty er voice oh no this is
nice this isn't it oh sorry
well the map says it is yeah well this
is it then I live it's almost there yeah
right there because it here's fine
unless the name of your street is the
name of my childhood street well don't
have people do the research
yeah well Chris if anyone figures out
has been here dit oh my god if I ever
have by someone who isn't days oh that's
just rude it would take that away from
Dan this is a very fun way to do a
podcast right yeah yeah and come home
from a gig
yeah and now I get to smoke pot until it
play on my cat so that'll be good too
that is good that's those are two things
I love to do not all right let's keep
the party going
where Adam we're at a perfect time to
stop okay
thank you for having me give me any
plugs I will be you know there's some
stuff oh I'll be in uh August 26th
be in New York and I I'm not going to be
good at this part I don't have a net
effect I I never get specific I'm not
good at this and then listen to the
podcast called the dollop with Garrett
Reynolds and Dave Anthony on all things
comedy yes and I have another one called
point versus point that is insane okay
that's all I'll say oh that's great
okay you know I'm excited to get some El
Pollo Loco and what's your Twitter
handle Oh Chris I just started following
you on Instagram well here we go we're
getting there I don't know I wasn't sad
that happens that does happen I'm at
Reynolds Gareth on uh-oh backwards man
yeah well because the Welsh guy beat me
to the punch on a lot of the social
media when he tweets of ever ever me
what I know it seems like he watches
rugby for a living as far as I could
tell he watches rugby in football and
and basically at this point forwards
between old has to be a main part of
what he does ah thanks all that's so
here we go buddy I think you did this
one
I got you real not that's all he does
and and so go to Garrett's Twitter to
find out where specifically in shows are
yeah I'm what are you doing what go to
get it where are you doing any lines
shows I think I've given up stand-up
comedy talking comedy again for now do
you really yeah well sure busy with what
did you because of work in the podcast
doesn't work the podcast in a fact items
I just use correcto though shows yeah
where you're going to go on the road
again with your podcast oh yeah we're
going to do High Plains Festival in
August that's in Denver go to Denver
where everyone wherever you live head to
head to Denver Denver I think I have a
show with Brian Posehn at the end of
this month next on the 25th I believe
it's Brian Posehn and friends at Largo
Oh that'll be great logo if you're in
Los Angeles it's a great place to go and
I think I'm going to do music not I
think I'm done with talking comedy again
done with the stand-up I can't I just
can't because of yeah I just can't write
bits I just don't believe in myself I
believe in I like when you write bits
but I also like when you do music and I
know
thank you both side rows that you should
do that guys thanks all the in San
Francisco next month sometimes whatever
anyway I'm going to just switch to music
ah
I'm just thinking okay I've got that
Jack guy right there yeah tried so hard
to look like he's not trying that's the
mayor of the city for sure he had it
definitely had an oval view home perm
yes there was no question that was not a
natural curl the DiGiorno is a douchebag
you've been listening to do you need a
ride
and I did do you is hey that's illegal
around here I leave in AI way bad either
way we want me to doesn't matter how
much thank you
please give a time and a Turner
we want to send you um you wanna welcome
you back home tell us all about it
we scared fine
[Music]
do you need a ride do you mean tonight
do you need do you need a ride do you
need with Curt and Chris